في حين قد يعتقد البعض أن هذه
السمكة ذات اللحم الأزرق تبدو مباشرة من
كتاب دو سوس، فقد كانت في الواقع خارجة مباشرة
من مياه ألاسكا لدينا، حيث كنا
نصطاد الصخور وكنا نصطاد الكثير والكثير
من الأسماك الخضراء، وقد ظهرت هذه السمكة
هناك، مالك جو شيك  نشر The Lodge At
Otter Cove وHomer كتاب التلوين الخاص به وهو عبارة عن منحدر أخضر
صخري على
Facebook قائلًا جزئيًا إن الطبيعة الأم
لا تصدق وحيويتها عندما تمت
مشاركتها على نطاق واسع وتفاعل معها الآلاف من
الأشخاص، لم يكن لدي أي فكرة عن أن أي شيء من هذا القبيل
سيحدث.  لقد كنت
مجنونًا تمامًا، وأعتقد أن هناك في الواقع 17
دولة مختلفة قد شاهدت هذا المنشور حتى الآن، وهي
سمكة ذات مظهر غريب وسام
من شأنها أن تربك حتى
الصيادين الأكثر خبرة الذين اصطدنا واحدة منها منذ
عام تقريبًا
ونحن خائفون بعض الشيء من ذلك  لم أكن أعرف
ما إذا كانت سامة أم ما هي
عادة عندما تكون ملونة للغاية،
لقد قيل لي أن السمك ملون أكثر كلما كان
أكثر خطورة ولكن السمك
آمن تمامًا للأكل
ويتغير لون اللحم من الأزرق إلى الأبيض عند طهيه
سمكة لذيذة ورائعة حقًا وفقًا
لعالم الأحياء في إدارة الأسماك والصيد في ألاسكا، دونالد آرثر، فإن اللحم الأزرق الذي
يظهر أيضًا في الرابط ينتج عن
صبغة صفراء خضراء تسمى بيلا فيردن،
وبينما يعرف العلماء مصدرها، إلا أنهم
ما زالوا غير متأكدين من السبب وراء ذلك.
يمكن أن يكون نتيجة لنظام غذائي للأشعة فوق البنفسجية
أو علم الوراثة الذي أضافه آرثر والذي يظهر أنه
عندما تقوم بالصيد في ألاسكا
فإنك لا تعرف أبدًا ما الذي ستحصل عليه